hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of Science
and Technology and I see um
uh all kinds of interesting questions
here or there's one that that catches my
eye from
uh AI owl
um it's about uh what is some history of
thermodynamics you found interesting
well working on my new project yeah so
I've been doing uh the last few weeks
I've been studying the history of
thermodynamics
um and the history of people
trying to
uh understand the second law of
Thermodynamics so I could give you a
little bit of a sketch of that I suppose
um maybe I'll have a chance to do a more
organized sketch some other time
um but uh sort of the the beginning of
that story is the question of what is
heat
and
back in Antiquity people had well you
know they were the atomists like
Democritus and lucipus and the
epicureans who had the idea that
everything was made of discrete uh un
indivisible objects that they called
atoms and actually to me it was a very
interesting idea that all the different
things we see in the world can be made
from a small number of component parts
sort of all assembled in different ways
I mean it was a thing that for example
lucretia's First Century A.D kind of
captured that idea by talking about the
fact that in a human language you have a
certain set of letters and it's a
discreet set of letters and yet you can
put together all of these things that
one can say in human language just from
The sub-discrete Limited collection of
possible sort of atomic elements for the
language and I think the epicureans of
lucretius was one of them uh kind of
thought of the world as being put
together
from sort of a small number of discrete
elements much like languages put
together from from discrete elements
like letters and so on now they tended
to have you know five or so different
kinds of basic elements you know water
and air and fire and some other things
and for them heat was
uh the fire component and they had this
idea that the atoms were different
shapes and I think that the heat atoms
the fire atoms were kind of pointy
things that kind of could get between
other atoms and that's how heat was kind
of transmitted from one thing to another
that was the theory of heat back in
antiquity
and
I think that theory of heat
kind of eventually
uh
well
became eventually the theory of caloric
um the idea that there would be some
some substance that suffuses things that
is heat
and that caloric is uh you know when
when heat is transmitted from one object
to another it's because caloric fluid is
going from one object to another and
that was something I think I think
Descartes who invented the term molecule
um and was sort of a a uh was taking off
I suppose from the Epicurean tradition
the atomic tradition of antiquity and he
had this idea of these sort of vortices
that would um uh that would be what
things were made of but he had a sort of
similar idea of what heat was but I
think then this this idea of caloric
emerged it had some relationship to
floriston which was a kind of substance
that was supposed to be produced in
things like combustion as a chemical
kind of thing and it was something that
was again a a thing that would flow from
one place to another and it would be
somehow there was a sort of conservation
of caloric there was a conservation of
heat in some way now then people also
later on started thinking about radiant
heat that is the the radiation
transmission of heat energy through
radiation and they had caloric rays and
all kinds of weird things that developed
from that but this idea of caloric was a
was a long-term idea about how heat
worked and it really survived up until
well the mid-1800s
um and people like LaPlace and was
writing about
um uh sort of the theory of caloric and
and so on and I suppose I mean this
history let me just say the whole of
this history is a mess there are many
strands there are many inconsistencies
there are many places where people
didn't understand what was going on and
so on but I mean another piece of the
whole picture uh was the question of
what gases are and how gases relate to
this idea of of molecules and so on
and um the uh
I think probably a sort of an important
part of that was Robert Boyle
1666 as I recall uh with this paper that
he wrote about the spring of the air
um which was about the fact that when
you squash air it pushes back and he had
these two theories that he talked about
that it was like a fleece of wool where
there were little Springs between
between the atoms of air or that it was
kind of a Vortex like story where things
were kind of bumping into each other in
the kind of Descartes way now at that
point
uh the the kind of the the it's a fleece
of wool thing got more traction and
actually Newton jumped into that and has
a passage where he's trying to estimate
he's trying to figure out uh kind of
when you have a um uh a a a
Celestial body that's made of fluid
um what is the uh made of made of a gas
for example what configuration would
that take up under Gravity and I realize
maybe I've talked about this uh before
on these um live streams I I maybe two
weeks ago I already learned about some
of these things
um so uh tell me if I'm repeating myself
um
the um
but anyway the the thing so there was a
you know so then Newton had sort of
weighed in on the fact that well
actually what must be happening is that
gases were made of these molecules which
had four slaws not the standard Newton
uh inverse Square law but another kind
of Law and he had he had sort of an idea
for what that law had to be in order to
reproduce Boyle's Law of pressure times
volume Mixels constant for a gas but but
in any case through all of this time
kind of the idea of heat as caloric was
a thing and you know like Galileo and
the beginning of the 1600s
um was starting to invent the
thermometer so to speak they had a way
of of having you know fluid pushed up
through a through a tube
um to determine uh as a sort of
quantitative way to to measure
temperature
um and people
so then
sort of the thing that broke the kind of
caloric theory of heat was when people
started really trying to understand what
gases were and started developing the
kinetic theory of gases and that was
something that really developed I guess
in the 1850s
um with people like James Clark Maxwell
um studying things like the distribution
of velocities of of a gas and being able
to start Computing if there were
molecules in a gas you know how would
those what would the actual sort of
kinematics of those molecules be like
and what effects would that have on the
large-scale properties of the gas and
could you derive you know PV equals
constant and so on now now they've been
previous work I mean Daniel Bernoulli in
1738 in his heterodynamic a book about
hydrodynamics has a section where he
absolutely talks about the kinetic
theory of gases but that was sort of a
lost thing in in history for for about a
hundred years and then there were a
couple of folks who um I was a guy
called heropath John heropath
um who figured out things about kinetic
theory in the
maybe 1820s or so but he had didn't have
a good luck because he was a um
I think he was a an instructor of the
East India Company
um math kind of instructor in the East
India company and he wrote this this
book which was which is kind of a one of
these sort of let me explain everything
in the world type books but one section
of it is about the kinetic theory of
gases was quite quite sensible but but
then he took that that the section about
kinetic theory of gases and he sent it
in as a paper to the Royal Society and
somebody wrote this is all nonsense and
it sat in the archives of the Royal
Society until pretty much the end of the
1800s
um when uh Raleigh really was it early I
think it was really yeah
um who was then Secretary of the Royal
Society published it with a note that
said I should explain why it is that
this paper was delayed by I don't know
50 years or something and it's
publication and you know it's because
well these people who come from sort of
uh from the you know don't have any kind
lineage that that people can trace and
they're they're suggesting unexpected
ideas you know how can we do better than
just reject it and put it away for 50
years
um but it's it's a it's a better written
apology than that
um but anyway it
um
uh
but kinetic theory of gases became a
thing by the mid-1800s meanwhile in the
theory of heat uh the sort of the big
figure was sadiqano very confusingly
there was another sadiqano who was a
nephew of the original one the other
City Kano became president of France at
some point and so you can be very
confused if you're looking these people
up
um but the city conno we're talking
about was
um uh what was particularly notable
about him he had his his uh his father
was a person called Lazar Kano who uh
was a
um a kind of a political figure who
managed to sort of be a big wheel in the
French Revolution and a big wheel with
Napoleon and a bunch of military things
for Napoleon and he managed to survive
all of that stuff without you know
running into some horrible political
disaster and part of how he survived was
that when he was out of favor he would
go off and be a math professor
um and uh he developed this whole
elaborate theory of machines and this
idea of what would make machines able to
run a kind of what what optimized the
running of machines and one of the
things he discovered was when when
things sort of hit things and with
percussion or other kinds of kinds of
things like that this leads to
inefficiency in machines it leads to
things being uh and so you want a
machine to kind of run smoothly and that
makes it the most efficient that it can
be given the structure that it has with
cogs and gears and whatever else
now meanwhile
uh this was at a time so that was Lazar
Kano then by 18 the 1820s uh one of the
things that had happened was the
development of the steam engine so the
steam engine was originally uh well
they've been precursors in Antiquity but
the original versions the newcomen
engine and things were kind of early
1700s and then um uh the steam engine
got progressively more efficient
particularly in England that was kind of
the the the center of steam engine
technology and and in England that I
think one of the driving forces was that
uh the uh you know coal was a big thing
in England and was starting to drive the
beginning of the Industrial Revolution
and the problem was and it's so much
modern like modern times uh you know
you're kind of getting coal out coal
mines and the coal that is easy to get
you managed to mine that fairly easily
and then there is Coley you really want
but it's deeper than than the other coal
and they had trouble that their minds
were filling up with water and so they
needed a pumping system to pump the
mines and that was what the first steam
engines were were first deployed for was
pumping mines and was critical to the
British economy to be able to do that
and um uh to be able to but
progressively has got more efficient and
so James Watt I think 1776
um
developed uh you know his engine and so
then the question was how efficient
could steam engines be and this was a
thing where uh
had been into the efficiency of
Machinery in general and had actually
been an inspector of gadgets for
Napoleon and had seen demos of steam
engines and things like this uh and even
a paddle steam I think was there was
another demo on the on the San River and
so on that was was given and that was at
a time when sudikano was a teenager and
kind of being homeschooled
so no doubt store all of those things
so then I think 1823 Los arcano dies and
salikano by the next year publishes his
book called on the Motive Power of heat
um and you know I don't think I don't
know actually I haven't looked I I don't
know if there's a car no archive
anywhere that can help one trace the
relationship between the father and the
son so to speak but the sun was by this
point a somewhat undistinguished uh
military engineer
um so I I don't I don't know what the
relationship of just sort of whether
there's actual material inside econo's
piece that was was from lazakano or
whether just it's sort of a a conceptual
development but Kano so the Econo works
out this notion of uh kind of the
efficiency of of heat engines and he has
this idea of a heat engine because a
steam engine is something which operates
with steam as it's working fluid and you
could imagine something which would
operate with I don't know Air instead of
hot air instead of instead of steam as
the working fluid but uh what Kano
realizes didn't matter what the working
fluid was there were conclusions you
could draw about the efficiency of any
heat engine and he had the idea that it
was all kind of talking about what was
really going on there was the working
fluid was really in a sense caloric
um and uh uh and then he was able to
work out the sort of formal results
about the efficiencies proportional to
these differences of absolute
temperatures and so on
um and then the big surprise later on
was that that result survived the fact
that caloric wasn't the correct Theory
but at the time Kano was operating as a
correct Theory Kano invented uh uh a
version of the second war of
thermodynamics to talk about the thermal
equilibrium and and he talked about
reversible processes in the in his
engine and so on but then it's next sort
of big thing was 1850s when um uh well
1840s I guess was um James Prescott
Jewel and count Rumford who were sort of
the people who tried to identify the
mechanical equivalence of heat that is
to what extent is heat something which
is independent is there a mechanical
correspondence
mechanical energy correspondence to the
to the energy associated with heat it
wasn't obvious that heat was sort of a
form of energy in the same way that
kinetic energy was I mean at the time
connected was always called visviva the
uh life force so to speak
um and uh I guess Rumford did um this
thing of drilling out cannons and then
Jewel had a thing with paddle wheels and
water and from their work came this idea
that heat really was a form of energy
somehow interchangeable with mechanical
energy and that observation led well uh
William Thompson later Lord Kelvin
um to kind of realize that oh well
actually uh he probably isn't you know
might not be caloric it might be
something different
um it might be a form of form of energy
and potentially uh microscopic motion of
molecules and so on
um and can one you know know this Kano
idea how does that work when you have
um
when it isn't about caloric fluid and um
so that that's then he uh both he and
and Rudolph clausius developed this idea
of um uh which led to the second world
thermodynamics you know this is a long
story maybe I shouldn't tell the story
now I can keep going but but this story
will will go all the way until the early
19 into the early 20th century
um and uh it's a little bit of an
anti-climactic story because a lot got
done a lot of different people were
involved particularly clausius Kelvin uh
Maxwell and then boltzmann and then
Gibbs
um and a lot of kind of the setup for
the second world thermodynamics got
built in the 19th century and then what
gibbs's work was like 1902 or so
um and then it's kind of like that's the
that's the origin material and then not
a lot happened in the 20th century in
terms of foundational questions and this
is what I've worked on from a science
point of view recently is to try to
understand how we can now make progress
on these foundational questions I think
we've been able to make a lot of
progress there but maybe this is a
different um
um
uh a different question you know Brady
is asking what makes water the best
substance to boil to produce steam power
or do people use other fluids I I don't
know whether nowadays they use other
fluids but but back then they certainly
did have tables of different kinds of
fluids and what and what their various
characteristics were and their heat
capacities and things like this and I I
don't know
um I think you know it's very convenient
to use water because it's an easy Supply
um all right let's see let me let me go
back to some other questions here
because I don't want to get spend my
whole time talking about Dynamics even
though I've been um
talking about some thinking about this
uh quite a bit
um
a couple of interesting questions here
right it's a question from blank on
what's the history of mathematical rigor
it's an interesting question uh I mean I
suppose
the Babylonians who were kind of The
Originators of the Strand that leads to
Modern mathematics
well not particularly rigorous in our
modern sense
they were much more of a just get the
answer
um now they did invent they did want the
answer symbolically they didn't just
want things like oh let's draw a picture
of that geometrical figure and then you
know measure how many squares of uh how
many times we can put our thumb on the
picture type thing
um no they wanted calculational answers
um but I don't think one could say that
they were
um
that they were sort of into the proving
of things now one important feature
about mathematical rigor is where it
really gets important is when there's
Infinities and infinitesimals involved
because in some sense you can always you
know you want to know the area of a
triangle you draw the triangle out on
the sand and you kind of measure or you
make it out of a piece of wood and you
weigh the piece of wood and you know you
can you can figure that out it's an
explicit thing just like a lot of modern
computation you can just explicitly work
out the computation and having a proof
of the answer is is sort of irrelevant
the the you know you just compute the
answer but the time when things get
really you know when you really start to
have to worry about uh kind of more
rigorous proof types of things is when
you're dealing with Infinities or
infinitesimals now in Geometry there's
always the question of are these
parallel lines exactly parallel
or are they just roughly parallel and
they meet a long way away those kinds of
things
and I think when people got more serious
about geometry that maybe where sort of
this efforts of rigor began to come in
because for arithmetic it's not so
important I mean it is you compute what
you compute and you know mostly ones and
then you get that answer
um
I think well an example of a of an early
piece of kind of mathematical rigor was
from the pythagoreans 5th Century BC
um where they had this idea that
rational numbers were sort of the story
of everything they noticed that musical
harmonies tended to be in rational
ratios they noticed a lot of other
features of things being irrational
ratios and then they looked at square
root of two and then shocker turned out
square root of 2 was not irrational
and I suppose that will be an example of
an early piece of kind of rigor in
mathematics was the realization that you
could you know you could prove that
square root of 2 couldn't be a rational
number and that was something that
required something Beyond just oh let's
calculated and find out it's roughly
1.414 or whatever it is
um so
but I think that the real sort of origin
point of a lot of this stuff is is
Euclid
um and uh Euclid presumably was was
partly collecting things that have been
discovered in Babylon and other places
he presumably worked in Alexandria or in
Egypt at the library there which was
sort of an early University
um and uh you know he collected his
Elements which is uh in which he wanted
to deduce geometry rigorously you know
he had you know 10 axioms basically from
which he wanted to deduce 400 theorems
and although he didn't write down the
proofs you know he wrote his his uh
elements down in kind of the form of
this is true this is true this is true
but the sort of the whole point was that
these things could be rigorously proved
and people like Plato picked up on that
notion of of uh uh well had had that
idea of kind of rigorous proof of things
and
so I think I think it was sort of the
origin point was the whole Plato Euclid
uh you know things that are necessarily
true about the world things that are
deducible by by sort of uh uh logical
inference rather than just observation
of the world the deductive versus
inductive truths things like this
but you know that was that was then
then there was a vast period of time
when there wasn't a lot of interest in
rigor and Mathematics
um I think that
um
the the thing that probably
um
well
the thing that really I would say
launched
sort of serious rigor in mathematics was
when one was talking about things like
numbers where everybody sort of knew
what a number was there was less need to
have sort of an elaborate formal Theory
by the time when it had in the 1830s
both galwa theory for gawa and and the
idea of groups mathematical groups and
lobachevsky and the idea of uh of
non-flat spaces
um these were things which were sort of
abstract and they're not amenable to oh
let's just you know write down some
number of tally marks or Draw this
geometrical figure
um and so I think that drove a certain
amount of sort of higher sophistication
in the way to think about mathematics
another thing that happened and this
must have been the very early 1800s
um was the notion of kind of rigor for
calculus I mean people in the hands of
of Newton and leibniz you know Newton
have done this very geometrical set of
derivations of calculus leibniz a bit
more algebraic but I and the idea was
that these were deductions like Newton
very much based his work on Euclid
um but I think it was
the the notion of exactly what does it
mean to have you know continuity and
limits and you know how does it really
work and does every function is every
function that you can draw a continuous
function what happens if you try and
take a limit where the function isn't
continuous these kinds of things that is
something that um
was in the beginning of the 1800s I
think uh was something that was very
much a French kind of tradition of let's
be more careful and I I think um oh gosh
who is it um not Dumber
um oh my uh
French mathematician around the end of
the 1700s
um who
was beginning to get more serious about
sort of making calculus rigorous I mean
I would say even people like Euler were
sort of working out answers with
Calculus very effectively but I don't
think we're as concerned with the kind
of niceties of can we really Define this
function is this really this really
worked this way and that was the thing
that was was very much a I think a
French tradition and um for example in
England people were like practitioners
of calculus I know Charles Babbage for
example was very enamored of the French
sort of formal School of thinking about
calculus and really wanted to import
that into into England which he didn't
really succeed in doing and in England
people were like much more let's work
out you know the equation for the motion
of a top and let's figure out you know
all this calculus derivations rather
than let's define what it means to be an
abstract functional let's define the
notion of continuity and so on I think
that was something that really came in
as I say in the sort of French tradition
of trying to do calculus
then
I mean there's there's sort of a
different tradition that branched off
from that which was the tradition of
kind of the formalization of mathematics
and that was people like David Hilbert
towards the end of the 1800s and people
like Giuseppe piano and so on around the
same time you know Hilbert his sort of
big breakout success was that he did a
non-constructive proof he did a proof
where he could show a result by saying
this exists but we won't actually
produce it
and that idea that you could make a
proof that was non-constructive like
that kind of takes you away from it's
kind of another Step Beyond kind of the
Infinities and infinitesimals it takes
you away from the the Practical the the
computational I don't think it's a
correct direction I think it's a it's
kind of an unfortunate Direction but
that was the direction that was taken
then and as a result of that I think
Hilbert became very sort of enamored of
this more formal approach to mathematics
where you could just you know Define
things formally as he said you know you
could have axioms that aren't really
about anything it could be talking about
tables and chairs and we'd still be able
to derive results of mathematics
axiomatically from these axioms and have
them be correct deductions the same kind
of way that Euclid had had deductions
from axioms and so on but I think then
this idea even if you look at works in
the late 1800s
um of mathematics uh you know even some
of these things I've looked
what's up with the Dynamics
um they're very physicist style uh
treatments of mathematics I I was amused
that um uh clausius in talking about
entropy says um uh
the closest yeah I think it's clausius
who has something that says um and the
entropy will
no no it must be boltzmann because it's
a discreet thing it's the the the the
thing will be
um a a positive number of energy units
or something is is transformed he says
that 1872-ish or something like that by
five years later he said a non-negative
number of energy units because that's
the correct mathematical statement but
earlier than that he was just playing
physicist so to speak and just trying to
get to An Answer without all the sort of
niceties of mathematics and and that
really was the tradition of um uh of of
most of that work and I think for
example in phonics Gibbs became much
more formal around 1902
um but many of those people were just
doing sort of physicist style
mathematics and the question of of what
um of kind of um when mathematics got
rigorized a big sort of push was the
French bobaki movement
um was kind of an attempt that was in
the 1930s or so was an attempt to kind
of uh redo mathematics in a more
rigorous kind of way
um and uh but that had for example very
little interaction with physics
wasn't until much much later that there
was an interaction between that sort of
formal more formally rigorous
mathematics and and what one saw in in
the applications of mathematics for
example in physics
and I think then
in modern times uh kind of the do the
corner cases matter as a big issue I
mean like uh mandelbras always used to
talk about fractals as being the sort of
monstrous curves that people had
identified back at the end of the 1800s
beginning of the 1900s as kind of these
exceptions to calculus because they had
all these discontinuities in them and so
on and at the time people had sort of
said well there are these exceptions but
we don't really care about them and then
later on uh and then by the time people
were being very careful instead of the
bobaki school it was like well let's
make sure our definitions exclude the
pathological cases and then later on
Belmont mandelbrot said actually the
pathological cases are the things that
are interesting for the natural world
and that's what in the 1970s led to
fractals and so on so you know what was
something that came out as kind of a
corner case a footnote so to speak to
the mathematical rigorization process
ended up being a thing that was Central
to physics and you know this has
happened a bunch of times I mean there
are plenty of cases where physicists
have this habit of sort of just rolling
in with with methods that work and the
mathematicians are like it's going to
take us another 50 years or 100 years to
turn that into something rigorous I mean
a good example there is probably in
motion which had been studied by
Einstein and smart smartkowski
um around uh well 1905 1900 those kinds
of times this notion of stochastic
calculus stochastic processes random
processes was mathematicized much later
than sort of the physicist delivery of
those kinds of things
um and the same is true like with path
integrals invented by dick Feynman in
the 1940s for physics
um it's still the case people are like
what the heck does this mean
mathematically you know it's a it's
still very hard to Define in a formal
mathematical way
um but it's something where you can do a
lot of physics with without ever knowing
the formal mathematical definition I
will say that in our physics project we
have a kind of a a giant boatload of new
kind of things that are relevant for
physics and limits of hypergraphs and
causal graphs and all these kinds of
things where we can kind of see to the
see our way through these things at a
sort of physics level of mathematics but
to really nail that down rigorously at
the level of pure mathematics is a
challenging process that will take a
long time
um I think when we look at
thermodynamics for example the attempt
to rigorize thermodynamics simply failed
it it was tried it has been tried again
over the course of the last hundred
years or so it simply failed I think I
Now understand something about how
thermodynamics Works sort of
computationally you can kind of see that
what what really happened was that
thermodynamics is something that pokes
out of the traditional kinds of things
that mathematics can talk about and it
is something that really requires sort
of a computational approach and an idea
of a theory of the Observer and things
like this which are things that
mathematics just doesn't have things to
say about
um so that that's uh that's been kind of
the the interesting thing there
um
let's see
uh
let's see there's another
question here
um
some questions here I don't know this
well
[Music]
um
boy this is one I should know and I
don't from cat what's the history of
chocolate what technology allowed the
creation of chocolate candies to become
so popular I can say only fragments and
I'm afraid I'm not gonna do a good job I
mean I think that was the the food of
the Gods from the Incas right was was uh
chocolate in in Peru and such like and I
think uh it was kind of brought back
from the new world
and um the uh uh
you know they're these big cocoa bean
thingies that um a big
I don't know the like red color that I
think in there they're very they're big
and they you know I don't know what's
involved in the harvesting I do know
that that somehow in the in the 1800s in
England
um some of my sort of favorite chocolate
companies like cadburys and things like
that were were very um they had a lot of
entanglement with kind of the the Quaker
movement and uh various kinds of um uh
um sort of uh uh charity work and so on
um I I but I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm not I'm
not up on what was the technological
thing that allowed uh sort of the um uh
um the refining of chocolate to work
smoothly I'm so sorry I don't know don't
know the answer to that
um and now dangerously going into
another one I'm not sure I know
completely from David on the history of
computer architecture and computer
software
are
who are the pioneers of parallel
processing parallel computing
let me talk a little bit about that
um
when
the idea that there is a single
processor a single place where the
instructions go through
that idea is a pretty old idea I mean
even babbage's analytical engine from
the 1830s 1840s had this idea of what he
called The Mill which was his CPU and
things will be sort of fetched for
memory brought to the mill it's a you
know that's a term of his time the mill
was where things got made
um you know like the the mill on a river
and things like this
um and um uh the um and then and then
processed there and then put back out uh
sort of into memory and and uh onto
punch cards or whatever else so that
that idea existed from that time Turing
machines famously are are sequential
processing devices they have a single
head that is the place where all the
action happens now interestingly other
models of computation didn't really have
that idea so for example recursive
functions which were another idea for of
a model of computation you've got this
functioning of computing a Fibonacci
number and you've you're Computing this
value of the fibon archery function and
over here you're Computing that value
and those in a sense could be thought of
as happening in parallel there's no
notion of oh and you sequentialize it
and there's just one place where where
things are happening now now similarly
combinators from 1920 another very early
model of computation I mean knowing
where the computation happens in
combinators is really complicated I just
wrote this book about combinators so
you're a couple year and a half ago
um
in which there are all these pictures of
of where does the computation actually
happen and it's it's you know
combinators have the feature that you
can always think about them as being
evaluated sequentially but in fact you
could as well do lots of updates in
parallel so they are sort of their
definition allows parallel processing
although you can think about them as
sequential processing as well
but then
uh
the um when it came to um
[Music]
um
so the development of early computers
and the anyac and things like this
um I believe all the early computers
were a sequential processing computers
um in in America they would be said to
have program counters in uh in British
English it was called the sequence
control register
um which was the thing that sequentially
went through the program and um and
evaluated things now
the earliest machines that were more
parallel famous one was the iliac 4
built at University of Illinois
um and that was a machine that had I
think it was a um a single instruction
multiple data machine where it had many
processing units which were each going
to do the same uh same processor they
were going to run the same piece of
program but on different parts of some
some data and I think there have been in
fact yeah there's a there's a different
branch of History here which is image
processing and early neural networks
so in image processing it's sort of a
quintessential example of where you've
got lots of pixels you want to do
something on the image but you might be
doing something locally on groups of
pixels and you know you can do that in
parallel across the image and I know the
iliac 4 was certainly used for that but
there were also early OCR systems in the
1950s that were actually based on
cellular automata oh yeah I should how
could I forget telling you about
cellular automata so uh you know in
addition to Turing machines the sort of
models of computation another early
model of computation was cellular
automata which were well invented many
times I even invented them once so to
speak
um and uh the one-dimensional version at
least I was something that I sort of
independently came up with
um before discovering that other people
had also come up with similar things at
least in two dimensions and kind of this
was a thing that um well had many
different Origins
um of just saying there's an array of
bits or of numbers and one will do an
update where locally in every section of
the array one says look at the
neighboring numbers then apply a rule
and uh see what the what the result is
and that was something that
um
uh people have done for many purposes
one of the famous examples was John Von
Neumann uh was trying to kind of make a
model of biology a mathematical model of
biology he'd been trained as a chemical
engineer and so one of his thoughts was
well let me you know think of biology as
really a chemical Factory and then let
me try and find a sort of mathematical
model of a chemical Factory and I think
uh his friend Oscar Morgenstern
um I think John Von Neiman was very uh
uh liked hanging out with kids and
playing with kids and so on I think
Oscar Morgenstern had some kids that uh
that he knew and they had a meccano
construction set and I think the um the
story is that um uh Von Neumann kind of
looked at this construction set and was
realizing oh maybe Morgan's didn't even
suggested this oh you can um uh you can
kind of have something that isn't the
full chemical Factory it's more like
something that's like an erector set
thing with a with a limited number of
components that you can assemble to make
something like biology and then uh
stanulam who'd been kind of in the in
the kind of uh uh polish School of of um
discrete mathematics have been studying
infinite matrices and so he kind of said
well why don't you simplify even further
instead of this three-dimensional
Factory why don't you just look at um a
two-dimensional array like a matrix and
just put bits in it and and that's how
509 and started thinking about this kind
of very complicated cellular automaton
whole book was completed after Long
Island's death by Arthur Burks of a
self-reproducing automata it was an
incredibly complicated construction
vastly more complicated than it needed
to be of a a cellular automaton with
this local update rule that would
um that would reproduce itself in a sort
of somewhat biological way but at the
same time there were also image
processing systems that were based on
sort of operations of um uh
that were based just on on local
operations between
um uh of neighboring cells as ways to
find edges and images and things like
that and there were a bunch of those
things in in the 1950s also there were
neural Nets and people were making kind
of Hardware versions of neural Nets even
sometimes to use for image recognition
and there again it was something where
multiple operations could be happening
in parallel because just wires
connecting things and I suppose I should
say as well that when it comes to
electric circuits electric circuits are
always doing things in parallel I mean
parallel circuits have been known
certainly since the time of kutchoff's
laws and the that must have been 1870s
or something
um the uh you know where people were
analyzing electric circuits
um that was uh parallel parallel
electricity was a well-known thing
parallel digital logic was not a
well-known thing and it was something
that existed in cellular automata but
they were of a different tradition than
the stored program computers and things
like that I think the iliac was was one
of the first machines that sort of
brought together this idea of of of of
parallelism in a sort of cellular
automatonish way together with
um the uh uh together with kind of an
actual sort of program that you could
write out in in some computer language
I'm embarrassed to say that I don't know
the names of the people who worked on
the Elliott four
um I should know them and I do not
um and uh but that started a traditional
parallel uh computation at Illinois
um that lasted lasted quite a long time
and there were different branches so
there was some
uh
the let's see by the
by the 1970s
there were
I mean this whole idea of parallel like
massively parallel computation had not
worked out terribly well
and
the because people sort of didn't know
how to make general purpose programs
that worked in parallel and so on and so
there have been a different tradition
which was vectorizing computation where
you would take a whole Vector of numbers
like a modern GPU and you would be able
to do computations on that in parallel
to that Vector but not in a more General
uh you know in a way where there will be
an instruction that would potentially do
this in parallel or you would be able to
have
um uh you'll be able to have some small
number perhaps what I should say better
is you could have a small number of
different essentially threads of
execution going on rather than something
where you'd have a number of processors
that was comparable to the number of
data elements you had so there was a
whole tradition of being able to write
for example compilers that could analyze
you know is this variable used earlier
or later in a loop and uh how does that
work
um and um uh you know can you make
um a sort of uh you know I think a
common thing was vectorizing compilers
and so on where can you can you do
parallelism at the level of oh we've got
a piece of Fortran code can we see that
this piece is an independent enough of
this piece but it can be run at the same
time on another processor on the machine
and and I know there was a lot of work
done on that by all sorts of different
groups I mean one person at Illinois
actually David Cook
um was a person who had a company that
did I think that company eventually was
absorbed by Intel
um um and that's a uh that was a kind of
a a a an effort to do this thing of of
sort of um uh being able to take sort of
a traditional piece of Fortran code or
or later C code and say what can be
paralyzed here in terms of small scale
parallelism in terms of larger scale
parallelism there were
um machines
well there were machines that were very
much array processing machines there was
a thing called the NPP which was a NASA
project the massively parallel processor
um and there was a
uh why am I thinking that Goodyear had a
project along those lines i i it's my
vague recollection
um this was in um
the late 1970s 1970s
um and you know another sort of data
point in this stream was the connection
machine computer that I was somewhat
involved with that was a Danny Hillis
um who'd been a student of Marvin
Minsky's that was sort of an AI inspired
production where there was this kind of
idea of you know AI is going to be about
making connections between things let's
make a computer where we can
fundamentally uh kind of encode the
notion of things being connected to
things I mean somewhat like what would
nowadays be you know the knowledge graph
I'm not a big believer in that
particular model of uh of knowledge
representation but it's it's an
interesting one and it has it has even
if it isn't for knowledge the graph of
of things as as that kind of fundamental
structure is interesting so that was
that must have been 1983 or so but that
got started and um uh that was kind of I
think I've talked about the history a
bit of thinking machines before
um that uh was an example of that was a
65 000 processor machine with rather
rather small processors per processor
but the idea was what you lost in the
individual processors being weak you
gained in the kind of number of
processors kind of a cellular
automaton-like idea except that that was
a machine which unlike these other kind
of array processing machines was a
machine where you could kind of Route
any any information to any other and any
anything to any other place in the
machine there was this language called
sea star that I tried to specify for
that machine which unfortunately
uh when it finally got developed was was
not as clean as as I had hoped
um but the idea was that uh you would
have this notion of a um uh sort of
pointers where that would correspond to
different processes and when you do and
see for example star and then a a a
pointer
um that that would uh you would be able
to basically route information through
the Machine by just specifying uh kind
of the processors as pointers in some
sense
um was it was um unfortunately the
actual Hardware construction of the
machine made that process much more
inefficient than one might theoretically
have expected it would be
um and so that was uh that was a that
was a problem there and I think you know
in a sense that the problem of the
massively parallel computer
um it hasn't really been solved even to
today and I think even some things that
we're doing now with our physics project
that have come out of sort of the the
understanding of how distributed
computation is done by the physical
world uh that seems to have some uh
Great Value actually in thinking about
sort of another generation of
distributed computing
um as a way to think about that
um
but I think I I may be terribly
forgetting
uh
um all sorts of people I mean I would
say also that the uh the super computer
tradition of cray Seymour cray and
people like that was was this kind of
vectorizing tradition
um not the kind of massively parallel
thing more take your Fortran program and
sort of make sure you know how you can
run this part of the of the code in this
part of the machine and that part
another part of the machine and so on
um
the uh
let's see
um
let's see
Aaron is asking
about uh Xanadu and um the hypertext
publishing technology so
um
Xanadu is the creation of a person
called Ted Nelson who's still around I
think
um I think one of my kids ran into him
recently or a few years ago at least
um
Ted Nelson had this idea of kind of the
this this idea of hypertext and this
whole kind of ecosystem of Xanadu that
was a way of sort of delivering
information to the world and I think it
was a kind of a a hypertext system that
was writable as well as readable and I
think it also came with sort of an
economic model
and this was a um uh
this was a thing in oh gosh when was
that that must have been in the 80s and
maybe
am I losing track of time here
uh yeah I think the 80s because they
were very Californian based uh operation
and um I think it somehow had a sort of
tentacles into transhumanism and things
like this
um but um
uh it's kind of a an idea now I I'm I'm
seeing if I can represent Ted Nelson's
ideas which I'm sure I cannot
um but he he has ideas that are still uh
have not been implemented I mean
hypertext and the idea of links in text
and so on is obviously very well known
and very well implemented but I think he
has an idea of some kind of
multi-dimensional kind of structure that
goes beyond just the straight links and
text and I don't think I can represent
that well but I think there's more to um
uh that can be discussed there
um
it's uh
um Aaron is also asking about the
history of canoe I I don't know it in
detail I've known Richard stallman off
and on for a long time
um I think uh
um I have to say I I will report the
conversation that I had once a very long
time ago uh uh with Richard solman who
was horrified by the fact that I uh
um somebody who's actually built
software that uh is is you know where
where the people who use the software uh
support the building of the software so
to speak rather than some more
complicated uh sort of business model of
of some you know more complicated open
source business model where you know you
make money by installing the software or
by giving people a version that actually
works or you make money from patents on
the software you make money uh because
you have a company that's doing other
things or you know a more indirect
process but uh he was was sort of
horrified at some at some point and I I
remember talking to him about about
um about canoe and um about uh you know
the value of giving things away and so
on and obviously we we give away lots of
things like access to Wolf malfur and
things like that and that's great and
and I like that very much and it's a
it's a fulfilling experience so to speak
um Richard was uh uh you know very big
on sort of giving away gnu and so on and
I many years later I I ran into him and
I and I ended up saying the one word
Linux
and that led to a a very long you know
Linux has just knew they stole it all
from us and it's like Richard I remember
you telling me you're giving it away you
know it's that's what happens if you
give it away and you tell everybody
you're giving it away
um then you know people take it and you
know that's
um so I I that's one little micro
anecdote I might tell
um I think there's uh um uh that there's
there's probably
um uh there's there's more and there's
there's hearsay and there's things I
know from from personal experience and
so on and there they're all a bit mixed
together
um
let's
see
um
ah let's see if there are any others
that I could address quickly
[Music]
um
Parker is asking about
cloud computing and how prevalent will
it be and how
will
the centralization versus
decentralization of computing it's sort
of interesting I'm reminded we were
talking about thinking machines I'm
reminded of a project that Danny and I
tried to do Danny Ellison I tried to do
of thinking about kind of the ultimate
limit of very powerful computers and
what would it be like if you could have
a sort of computer power station
that had just amazingly and maybe our
I'm sure I've got the notes from those
conversations which must have been in
the mid-1980s and um you know maybe
it'll be embarrassing to find out that
our computer power station is vastly
less powerful than you know a tiny Bay
of a big cloud cloud computing providers
um uh uh
um
uh uh Colo
um collocation data center
um
but any case back in those times you
know this whole issue of centralized
versus decentralized
it's a complicated economic
and infrastructure issue because you
know there was a time when it looked
like centralized Computing that's great
communication channels will be such that
you can just run everything on the
central computer and you'll get the
display and things will just be sent to
you for display
um that was a thing in the uh for
example a project uh done at
um Bell Labs the blit terminal done by
Rob Pike and uh collaborator of his
partner Cathy maybe
um the uh
um
uh that was kind of a a time when it
looked like one could have sort of a
Thin Client terminal but the real
computation would be gone on the back
end and by the way this was a great
thing for the phone company because
people will be buying more phone service
to have and the phone company would be
able to provide what would now be called
the cloud computing resources and one
would deliver uh things sort of uh just
to the terminal of the phone lines
and that model of computing didn't catch
on at that time instead it was the
workstation model and the personal
computer model and the decentralization
of computing I think in modern times
uh the you know the idea of
centralization is somewhat
for some
purposes it's the centralization of file
storage and the centralization of access
but there are different solutions to
that
in another it's that just keeping
large arrays of computers running is a
big pain and that's something that
there's economic Force to centralize I
mean I personally tend to think I mean
like our company we don't really use
outside cloud services for much
um because the scale of most of what we
do is such that it's worthwhile for us
to have our own uh data centers and so
on
um uh because it just is well it's more
economical that way and after all we're
a software company and so we should know
something about how to run those kinds
of um uh those kinds of computational uh
resources
so I mean I I tend to not think I mean
again it is this this strange thing
that's gone back and forth over the
course of time you know and then people
are very proud of the fact that you know
is the machine learning stuff happening
in the cloud or is it happening locally
oh it's so exciting that some of it can
happen more locally is the stuff
happening I mean it's kind of funny that
the the uh the thing the least likely
thing to become an operating system is
sort of become an operating system
namely browsers and you know people are
like well you know we can run uh and
it's kind of bizarre we can run things
you know in in webassembly that is a uh
that's running inside a JavaScript
interpreter that's running sort of C
code that has been transcompiled to
JavaScript running inside a browser
running on top of a computer's operating
system and that's what you're you're
running in so to speak and I think this
this whole question about sort of how
what's packaging of where the
computation gets done
is is an interesting one and there are
things like in the case of of browsers
things like the driver of security of uh
is is a you know can you where did this
program come from can I safely run it
will it be sandboxed and so on that's
certainly an unexpected driver in terms
of sort of the history of computing but
I think it's it's by no means
self-evident that sort of more
centralization of computing resources is
the way things are going or is even a
necessary idea I mean I I find that um
um
you know I do a certain amount of
large-scale computing and you know I
have a couple of hundred processors
sitting around my house basically which
I use for lots of parallel Computing and
only very occasionally for the things
I'm doing do I end up saying oh let me
use a few hundred cores
um in some Cloud uh system even though
the things I'm doing involve quite
large-scale Computing it's somehow you
know one case would be well oh that's
because I only need the the you know the
the overage Computing very rarely so I
don't want to own that stuff and I'll go
out and use some other some other
service but I I think it's uh you know
one of the use cases is you're going to
have a spike of usage and you want to
just be able to be in a bigger pool I I
don't think it's at all self-evident but
things will become more centralized in
terms of computing infrastructure
um
let's see maybe one more and then I
should uh go here
um
a lot of very open-ended questions here
which I think are
um oh boy his one's interesting
from Aaron can you talk about the
history of the Public's perception of
its own scientific literacy
it's an interesting question
you know
I was reading something
just yesterday actually day before
yesterday by a chap called CP snow
who was a novelist
um and uh civil servant in England 1959
he wrote a book called the two cultures
it is I have to say on my glance at a
rather pompous book
but it has this section which has been
widely quoted where he says you know
he's asked people uh you know can you
describe the second order of
thermodynamics that's why I was looking
at it recently
um and uh uh or can you quote something
from Shakespeare or whatever and people
at that time 1959 were very much of the
you know nobody could quote you know no
sort of generally educated person could
quote the second row of thermodynamics
but they could tell you pieces of
Shakespeare
and so his point was you know there
isn't scientific literacy people don't
uh you know it's it's sort of shocking
that there's this whole development in
our civilization of Science and the
average educated person doesn't know
anything about it
and I think that was a time in England
you know when I was a kid for example in
the 1960s early 1970s where scientific
knowledge at least I can talk about the
English case was still kind of a
specialist thing uh you know it was the
term buffin to refer to a scientist was
just going out of circulation and you
know newspaper headlines you know
buffins and vents such and such was just
kind of going out of circulation I would
say
um and it was uh but it was still the
case that
um uh you know
in a sense gentlemen weren't scientists
they were gentlemen scientists but um it
was something where you know a gentleman
was educated in you know Latin and Greek
and uh this and that but science that
was kind of a a you know that would be
like it would be like sort of learning
to uh do car mechanics or something like
this uh to some people it would be
something that um was uh
um you know seemed like a
non-intellectual not not a uh a a you
know a kind of a liberal arts
um kind of um
um
uh kind of pursuit and I think that what
changed that
um
probably
well in the U.S
the uh sort of the big rush of we should
care about science and we should educate
people about science came in partly from
the second world war and partly from
Sputnik
um and this sort of urgency in the 1960s
of you know let's get Science Education
up to Snuff
um probably started to change that
process but I think it's it's it's sort
of an interesting thing you know who is
proud and at what time are people proud
of not understanding science math
whatever there's certainly been a period
in my life you know there was a of
course I don't understand that science
stuff that's just for the Geeks so to
speak and I think that changed
sometime rather recently actually I
think the idea that people sort of are
are kind of maybe maybe part of the way
what changed that was the rise of the
geek CEO and um the kind of the rise of
the uh you know because it had been the
case before the Bill Gates's and Steve
Jobs of this world and so on that
they've been this kind of idea that that
you know CEO in a company was something
for the the generally educated person
not for the geeky you know I write code
and know about geeky math stuff kind of
person but then as it turned out there
were huge successes in the technology
sector that caused people with geeky
backgrounds so to speak to be the people
who were the natural CEOs and so and and
that was a phenomenon of the of the
1980s even 1990s
um that uh that people sort of the
respect for the um I mean I'm I'm I'm
I'm good with this it's kind of like um
then uh I mean even when I was starting
my company it was it was it was unusual
actually an interesting story there I
remember being at a computer conference
software conference this must have been
1988-89 something like that lots of uh
software company CEOs and various people
pointed out that of all the CEOs they're
the only two who could demo that product
themselves were myself and Bill Gates
so that's sort of an interesting thing
because that meant the other CEOs were
not geek CEOs so to speak and that was
you know sometime very late 1980s
um and and that I think has has changed
now and and maybe that has something to
do with the kind of the rise of kind of
uh you know you go to business school
and it's it's a feather in your cap to
say I know how to code rather than oh if
you know how to code you must be a geek
you must not be somebody who's headed
for the you know the corner office you
know uh senior slot so to speak so
that's probably one thing that's changed
I think that
um the idea
I mean the typical person
um
what level of sort of scientific
literacy does does a person have
um and uh
when
it's interesting when that's changed I
mean I would say that the um
um
it is
certainly in my lifetime I mean it's
it's not been
um you know in in the it's only been 40
50 years since that really wouldn't have
been seen as a as an important part of
general education to know things about
science
um and I suppose you know what other
what were some other anchor points there
I mean I think the success of some of
the the science documentary series like
Cosmos and so on
um was probably another uh another kind
of um marker moment in terms of science
Literacy for the public
um I think that um uh the the kind of um
the the fact and then I suppose another
thing is by the time when I'm not a
television Watcher so I can't tell you
about you know Big Bang Theory and
things like this but the enmeshing of
kind of uh science with kind of General
culture you know can you tell a science
joke and have anybody laugh type thing
um and can you have a a kind of a a
character in you know a a sort of a
general television show and so on who is
sort of uh
sciencey and have that be something
that's relatable is uh uh that's that's
that's kind of another probably another
uh sort of moment for science literacy I
mean I think that um
um uh I'm trying to think what am I
missing it's an interesting question
um I mean I think that uh
I'd like to
think well let's see I mean
yeah there have been sort of Rises and
Falls of science literacy features for
example for a long time Scientific
American was a very successful magazine
you know circulation three million
things like this
you know close to I think National
Geographic was five million at one point
you know it was a little bit above but
it was still you know Scientific
American was up there that was probably
in the in the 80s and things and it was
a thing that you would find along with
uh sort of the other kind of General
glossy magazines that you'd find in a
waiting room or something like this and
it was uh was kind of a a thing people
read
um I would say that uh at that time in
the 80s actually there was a real push
to get other science sort of popular
science magazines there was a I remember
there was a thing called science 86
which must have been around in 1986 and
there was science digest and a bunch of
these other things that got started in
the US they did not succeed
um and the science uh sections of
newspapers shriveled up over the course
of by the probably by the 2000s and they
were sort of gone now strangely they're
a phenomena like New Scientist magazine
a British magazine that um uh is
sometimes a fount of misinformation
um although it's it's kind of a it'll
have you know some article about some
science thing and it has a certain it
always has a certain
uh Whimsical character they tend to have
certain Whimsical character and it it
often ends with this may lead to
advances and whatever and it's like you
kind of roll your eyes a little bit at
it but it's intra to me it's interesting
um because it it raises questions and it
makes one think about things and
actually it's the it's the one magazine
that I have consistently subscribed to
for 53 years now
um and uh uh it's interesting that that
has survived as a newsstand magazine in
the UK and there is no comparable thing
in the US
I mean it's my
um uh that has been a Science News
Magazine which is this thin magazine
which I've also subscribed to for a long
time is a is a good uh sort of a U.S
analog but it isn't really this quite
the same kind of thing because new
scientists has definitely intended as a
um as a very uh for the people kind of
um uh uh thing whereas science news I
think is much more aimed at people who
are more in the science track directly I
I think New Scientist magazine if I
remember the start in the mid 50s and I
think somehow Winston Churchill was
somehow involved in its in its founding
and encouraging the fact that it should
be a thing so to speak I mean I think
that was um uh it was it was um but but
it's interesting that this notion of
kind of uh does the general public care
about science
um the survival or not of science
magazines popular science magazines sort
of an interesting Bellwether for that
for that type of thing
um and uh
um
let's see the the um
uh
yeah there's a common tip from from
Central but
science literacy
um
and uh
about memes and and different
subcultures emerging I
you know I don't know I think that um
um
you know it's worth remembering
that things like you know the the kind
of the the persuasiveness of Science and
its role in sort of the political
discourse has a very long history going
back to Francis Bacon who was like if
you tell them it's science they're not
going to dispute it if you just tell
them it's political opinion they'll
dispute it and that was kind of a very
early motivation for kind of uh sort of
the formalized scientific method I I'm
not sure it was a it's a kind of an
unfortunate piece of the history because
it kind of reveals the you know it's its
potential for abuse and so on but I
think it it's one of these things where
where
um uh this kind of idea that
um you should sort of listen to science
uh you know obviously in the 1600s
um with the whole you know Copernicus
and then the whole Galileo controversy
that was a very much of a of a very
early you know should you listen to
science or should you listen to the
church type thing or to or to you know
scripture or whatever
um that was a very early version of that
but I don't think that was I mean in in
in in modern times well I will say also
that I you know in the time of the
pandemic uh
you know one could be pretty horrified
by the level of science illiterus Say by
uh you know for example in news media of
people saying things that were just like
you can't be serious that was you know
that that's just you know Elementary
micro probiology or whatever or
elementary mathematics you know it just
doesn't work that way
um and you know unfortunately in in
those cases that got so intertwined with
political discourse that I don't know
whether anybody even knew that there was
a you know anybody who even thought or
we'd better figure out what's
scientifically true here only a subset
of people were were thinking that and
and that wasn't the main thrust and so I
think you know in in the case of um uh
you know that was not a shining example
of of science luxury on display on on
frankly on all sides
um you know of of uh of of kind of what
did it mean for epidemiology what did
you know what was when was transmission
going to work when were vaccines going
to work what was et cetera et cetera et
cetera it was it was a mess and um uh in
my view at least
um I think um uh uh and maybe one of the
problems there here's another Dynamic of
science literacy is the extent to which
its experts versus the public and the
extent to which people
in general
uh sort of believe in themselves enough
to believe they can understand this and
to what extent they're just the experts
have told us X Y and Z so we're going to
believe it so to speak and I think there
are I mean in a sense the test of of
true science literacy is that people
feel that they can reason about about
science
um not just I mean in a sense one could
take this to other domains where one can
say you know when do people think uh oh
I don't know they can they can reason
about literary Works they can have
reason about art and so on they can they
can you know
people in general can have opinions
about things which are which are
reasoned and sometimes in science it's
people and I and I like to think that
folks who who join us on these live
streams are in the category of people
who do think that they can think for
themselves and and figure stuff out and
so on and I I like to provide some
example of ability to do that
um I think it's it's a um I mean that's
a it's a very to me it's a it's a
wonderful thing and an important thing
for both individuals and for society in
general to actually be able to think
about things rather than just say oh
yeah an expert told me that I'm done
type thing and I think in science there
tends to be a certain
uh extent and it's sort of a cultural
thing in some ways that there are places
and times when people are like the
experts said that I'm done that's that's
all I need to know
um I mean I do think that um it's kind
of of a a you know when you think about
a science question where you see some
piece of of news that's of a scientific
kind you know it's always interesting to
ask yourself how do they know that you
know why do they think that you know
could they know that or is this a you
know a study that could not possibly
have been done because it just doesn't
make any sense or you could never get
that data or whatever else it's kind of
like you know can you do those extra
steps of thinking and I think that's a
that's a really worthwhile thing and the
extent to which that is something people
believe they can do something people can
do it's interesting and I I yeah
actually there's an interesting point
here which is and I should wrap up in a
moment here but but during this pandemic
one of the things that is quite
interesting is the extent to which
people
would have scientific opinions about
things
and
and to which you know you could have a
discussion which went oh
you know I'm convinced that the virus
has this or that characteristics and
it's going to have you know do this or
that thing and it's going to whatever
and I it is interesting because people
did seem sometimes way off base but but
somewhat more empowered to talk
scientifically about things than perhaps
they would have done 10 years earlier I
mean in other words that that perhaps 10
years earlier there would have been more
of the the typical person not being able
to you know just being able to say oh
the you know CDC who whatever it is that
whatever said blah therefore blah and
not be able to have a any oh I don't
think that can be right it's you know
Etc et cetera et cetera kind of thing
and it is interesting the extent to
which
uh you know what domains of science
people have an opinion
um you know it
um uh you certainly
couldn't um
um
there are domains of science where where
it's easier to have an opinion that
makes sense from just sort of general
knowledge of the science than other ones
but but um anyway the the
um GCB is asking we go back to science
illiteracy
um
I I don't know it's a question of the
education system you know most of the
stuff that people learn I well and and
media Communications social media things
like this it's like if if
you know you can you can induce
more I mean I try and do my small part
for science literacy
um by trying to just explain stuff
um I think that um
the
extent to which
look the the thing about science
literacy one of the things is
if you just
uh
you know it's a question of like how do
you teach science in school do you teach
facts about science do you teach uh
methodologies do you really teach
methodologies or does it segue into
opinions
um do you teach sort of the ability to
think about science or do you just teach
sort of the ability to answer and
exercise based on kind of receive
knowledge about science
um I think
that the really valuable thing is to be
able to have certain factual knowledge
and then to be able to teach and
understand kind of how to reason about
things
um based on on that factual knowledge
but I'm not sure the extent to which
that's taught because sometimes it's
some uh you know it's it's it's more
difficult to teach that because when you
let people go kind of free range
reasoning about things you don't
necessarily stay right within that that
zone of what teachers know about what
tests are about Etc but anyway shouldn't
get me started on that topic
um an interesting interesting topic for
another time
um I should run off here
um but thanks for joining me and um
see you another time bye for now